بالفعل لكن للتصحيح هي عائله مكونه من 15
شخصا لم ينجوا منها الا خمسه اشخاص بمعنى
ان هناك عشره اشخاص قضوا في هذا الزلزال
خالد هناك احمد ينضم الينا الان وهو احد
الناجين الذين استطاع الخروج من تحت
الانقاض وبالمناسبه هو الذي خرج لوحده لم
يعني ياتي احد لانقاضه او يعني استطاع ان
يخرج لوحده قبل ان تصل في فرق الانقاذ بعد
نحو تسع ساعات من الزلزال الذي ضرب مدينه
كهرمان مرعش سنتحدث مع احمد الان خالد
يعني نفهم خالد اللحظات الاولى من الزلزال
ممكن ان توصف لنا اياها كيف صار شو اللي
صار معكم
اول شيء كان في كنا نايمين الساعه اربعه
صار في زلزال كنا عاديين على جنب انا
وخالي واخي بغرفه والباقيين كانوا بغرفه
صار الزلزال ممكن توضح لنا كم شخص كانوا
بالبيت كانوا بالبيت الشخص على اكثر 12
شخص كان بالبيت انا وخالي واخي كنا بغرفه
قاعدين نايمين والباقي كانوا بغرفه صار
الزلزال ركدنا عليهم طلعناهم عند الباب
على السريع حاولنا نفتح الباب لكن الباب
من الزلزال ما احسنا نفتحه لانه كان راسس
على بعض فلم نستطيع فتحه حاولنا فتحه لوقت
طويل 12 شخص في البيت كلكم توجهتوا للباب
الخارجي
وحاولتوا تفتحوا الباب ما فتح نعم حاولنا
انا وخالي شيراز اكبر مني بسنتين الله
يرحمه حولنا وفتحه بقوه حاولنا اكسره ولا
لم يوافنا الوقت
وضرب الزلزال تاني اجتمعنا فوق بعض قدام
الباب باقرب مكان واحد بينبطح فيه وبطحنا
كلياتنا فوق بعض وكلياتنا صرنا بمكان واحد
واتضرب الزلزال الثاني ووعد فينا البنايه
يعني البنايه انهارت الثاني مش بالاول
انتم في الاول حاولتوا تهربوا ما استطعتوا
لكن في الزلزال الثاني نهار عليكم المبنى
بالزلزال تاني نهاره المبنى وما احسننا
نطلع منه
وبعد ما بعد هيك فتره ماهدي الوضع صرت
اشوف حالي وين انا اتطلع ما احسن كتير
اتحرك كنت عم بسمع صوت وراي صوت بنت خالي
بنت خالي ساميه اللي طلعت الحمد لله عايشه
وكان في بنت كمان عايشه
والباقيين كلياتهم كانوا ميتين قدامي شفت
اكتر شفت مرت خالي وخالي واخي وبناته
وبعد فتره راح احسنت اطلع بعد ساعتين لحتى
احسنت احرك حالي وعلى الساعه 12:30 وحده
حاولت اطلع وطلعت لفوق والحمد لله وجدت
فرق انقاذ ونزلتني لتحت
طلعت بيوم يمكن طلعت بنت خالي يعني انت
زحفت من بين الانقاض وطلعت لوحدك الحمد
لله اول شيء الله اللي طلعني وحاولت انا
ازحف ادور على اي طريقه اطلع بس منه انا
اطلع يمين يسار اروح امشي ازحف زحف يعني
الزحف حتى مو بايدي باصابع ايدي كان
الاماكن كتير ضيقه حاولت ازحف وطلعت الحمد
لله كله بفضل رب العالمين طلعنا
وطلعت لفوق ووجدت انقاذ تنزلني لتحت كيف
كانت اللحظات هاي يعني بعرف سؤال صعب
اللحظات يعني مرعبه الواحد ما له عارف شو
صاير فيها ماله حاسس بيا بشو صاير انا
يعني لما كنت تحت لما صار زلزال رجليك
فاقد الاحساس فيا ما راك تعرف موجوده
مقطوعه مكسوره يعني لحظات صدقا لا توصف
وكان عندي يعني انه خايف يصير شي كمان
زلزال تاني علينا ما بتعرف شو بده يصير
كمان
طب انت قلت انه في لحظه بس النهار السقف
كان في كمان شخصين معك بنتين على قيد
الحياه
نجوا ام لم ينجوا في بنت الحمد لله احس
انه يطلعوا اللي هي ساميه بنت خالي والبنت
التانيه الله يرحمها ما حسنت يعني الان
عشر اشخاص من عائلتك واقاربك توفوا في هذا
الزلزال عشره اعدلك اياهم
بالسته وخالي وخالتي ومرت خالي وبنات خالي
التنتين واخي واختي وابي وامي كلياتهم
توفوا ضللنا نحن هون خمس اشخاص حاليا
بتركيا طيب انت حاليا وضعك الصحي كيف شو
عندك اصابات محتاج لعلاج شو وضعك الحمد
لله يعني يعني علاجات الحمد لله ما يبعد
يعني اصابات طفيفه مالها الاصابات العاليه
ما الحمد لله يعني اصاباتي عاديه ما لها
اصابات عاليه او كسور او شيء الحمد لله ما
في شي